hey youtubers is Charlie so you all
probably have some theories about how
the flash is going to come back during
season four we all think it's going to
be a version of rebirth but there's a
lot of really complicated ideas in that
concept because there are two versions
of Reaper I'm going to talk about the
one that Geoff Johns wrote first because
I think that they're going to borrow
from both versions of rebirth so there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
we're going to be doing comic book stuff
all summer but the first flash rebirth
was all about the return of Barry Allen
from the Speed Force the second flash
rebirth was all about the return of the
ginger wally west from the Speed Force
so there was this big concept that Mark
Waid came up with during his Wally West
run back in the 90s where speedsters
drew on something called the speed field
that they later learned was called the
Speed Force
Wally learned he was connected to it on
a very fundamental level it was almost
like Jedi's using the Force like it's a
part of you it flows through you it's
part of all living things but only
speedsters are able to tap into it like
you saw avatar at the beginning of the
flash season 3 only the other speedsters
could see it that's because he was
trapped in the Speed Force so during the
Wally West's run they learned that when
speedsters die they don't die like
normal people they actually get sucked
up into the Speed Force as pure energy
so the flash TV show made this a little
more obvious like Barry was literally
walking into the Speed Force becoming
pure consciousness he just in a state of
pure energy beyond time so what happened
in the comics is is that Barry Allen
sacrificed himself during crisis on
Infinite Earths he seemingly died wally
west took up the mantle so our version
of wally is the main version of the
flash on the TV show right now they
think that Barry's dead they don't know
when he's going to come back but I'm
sure that there's some hope in them like
ok someday he'll come back the TV show
isn't that pessimistic about it in the
comics it was way different they thought
Barry was totally dead so what happens
is is at the end of final crisis the
Rogues sense that Barry Allen has
returned mysteriously so if you haven't
read Final Crisis don't worry about it
but it's at the end of row
revenge in arc where they kill the Bart
Allen speedster who is also an adult it
got really crazy they resurrected him
they brought him back his Kid Flash the
Geoff Johns flash rebirth was the art
that fix all that
so sometimes comics get a little bit
crazy then you have a rebirth that's
what they did last year sales had gotten
really bad with the new 52 things were
all crazy so like okay we're gonna fix
everything and we're going to call it DC
rebirth so Barry comes back and all the
people around the city are either
celebrating or they're getting prepared
like the Rogues are sitting here oh my
god we're going to need a whole lot of
more rogues the gorillas in gorilla City
paint this picture of the flash Barry
Allen's back because Gorilla Grodd was
one of his biggest villains so Grodd is
starting to freak out too and then
before he steps onto the stage in the
flash Museum they sort of preamble him
with all these people remembering
classic stories from the Barry Allen
Silver Age of comics remember the time
that that thinker in the shade stole
Keystone City and Barry Allen saved it
they phased it out of time that Jay
Garrick story is actually extra funny
now that we know that thinker is going
to be part of season four so maybe
they'll have some Easter eggs for that
story but Jay Garrick remembers how
Barry Allen inspired him to take up the
mantle again like he'd gotten kind of
burnt out about being the Golden Age
flash but Barry Allen came along and
reminded him what it was to be a hero so
he says Barry Allen is the reason that I
became the flash so all these people are
celebrating Barry's return it's sort of
a mirror for a flash day at the
beginning of season two if you remember
that everybody's like oh my god we love
the flash so much so all the while
nobody really understands how Barry
Allen's come back from the Speed Force
only that he's back they're really happy
iris is really happy they're just all
doing normal family things when all of a
sudden on the outskirts of town a couple
of kids find the remains of the black
flash and they're like oh my god Barry
outran the black flash that's how he
came back to the land of the living he
outran death literally comic books
avatar comes back from his before prison
the exact same thing happens he
disintegrates into nothingness as they
investigate to get attacked by lady
flash who's a villain he tries to stop
her but in this big feedback loop of
Speed Force energy she completely
disintegrates and then on the spot
Barry's costume changes and he gets
charged with negative energy becoming
the new black flash so he has this aura
of death about him and he can't touch
any of the other speedsters or get close
to them otherwise they'll disintegrate
too so this really cool story about
Barry Allen coming back from the dead
turns into a story of him becoming the
black flash and he doesn't know what's
going on only that they have to put him
in containment so they didn't poison the
other speedsters the TV show just got
rid of the first black flash I love the
way killer frost waves at him as he
slowly cracks into nothingness so
there's no black glass right now meaning
that somebody will have to take his
place eventually and if you're really
fun twist I'm hoping they have some fun
with this they could do things the flash
rebirth way but they tend to change the
comic book story just a little bit so
the story of how Barry became the black
flash is all about the reverse flash
being the one to bring him back from the
dead so this is actually the really cool
part reverse flash gets to be the hero
again those were some of my favorite
quotes from the beginning of the season
now you're the villain Barry Allen and
then as he's dragging him back so they
can wreak ill his mother he says I get
to be the hero of this time so in the
comic book the reverse flash brought
Barry Allen back by recreating the
experiment that gave him powers in a
slightly different way using the bolt of
lightning that gave Barry powers to
create the negative Speed Force bringing
him back this is where it gets a little
complicated because reverse flash
explains the way he brought Barry Allen
back was the send of pulse into the
Speed Force that brought Barry's
consciousness back but as he was doing
that he created the negative Speed Force
so as Barry was coming back he was
getting poisoned with negative Speed
Force energy which is what causes him to
become the black flash and start
canceling other speedsters out turning
them into dust so this is one of the
first big arcs where Geoff Johns started
to tell the story of how reverse flash
was responsible for all the Flash's pain
he goes back along his timeline he kills
Barry's mother so even though he can't
kill him he's trying to do everything he
can to hurt him but at the end of the
story he decides to go back and kill
iris West who is his speed force tether
she's sort of like the lightning rod
that Barry Allen is always grounded - so
when Barry Allen gets trapped in the
Speed Force
iris is sort of the thing that keeps him
grounded they did that during season
a little bit she's the thing that he
focuses on so reverse-flash gets the
idea to go back and kill iris west so
that he won't have that Wally and Barry
travel back into the past and while they
do while they're saving iris they become
the impetus for the lightning bolt that
gives Barry own powers in the first
place so it becomes this time loop where
the flash goes on to have all these
adventures but then sacrifices himself
to save other people but in doing so
becomes the bolt of lightning that gives
him powers so his life becomes this
closed electrical circuit like you die
you become energy the energy gives you
powers in the past then you become the
flash to sacrifice yourself become
energy again and it all starts over so
that's a little bit trippy the flash TV
show tends to make things way simpler
they did a flashpoint in a single
episode it was actually less than the
single episode so here's the thing in
episode 1 there has to be Grant Gustin
in some form so what we'll probably see
is everybody living their life just
going on like things have been normal
for the last three months and then we'll
get a teaser for some disaster some
phenomena that brings Barry Allen back
without anybody really understanding how
it happened or why it happened but then
they lay in the teaser for the return of
people like the reverse flash as well as
the other villains that are going to be
the main villains of season 4 which
isn't the reverse flash technically so
this is where we start to go left turn
from rebirth so they'll borrow some of
the big concepts but they could always
do something really wildly different
like turn the reverse flash into the
black flash temporarily there's just a
couple problems with doing big comic
book twists if you're not going to do
the full story because like the story of
how Barry Allen became the black flash
involves a lot of other things involved
the negative Speed Force the reverse
flash coming back so I'm expecting the
TV show to do it in a very very simple
way what we'll do is when we actually
see the episode we can take through the
actual flash rebirth Easter eggs and see
what other things they tease because
Barry Allen coming back is sort of the
tip-off point for everybody else raising
their game up the Rogues going into
hardcore mode the reverse flash coming
back really anything that happens to
Barry in the speed force can also happen
to the reverse flash they get a little
crazy when it comes to reverse flash it
just depends on what kind of story they
want to use them for if they don't want
to use them for a rebirth story then it
will probably be
version from earlier in his timeline
because we still haven't seen the
version where he gave himself the powers
of the flash reverse-engineering them
from Barry's costume so there's still a
lot of question marks but if you want to
read it I recommend reading the first
flash rebirth and then you read the
second one where Wally West came back
they're both amazing stories but geoff
johns is the one that wrote the first
one there were a lot of you that
requested more comic book videos this
summer they just did Lazarus contract
which is the story of how Deathstroke
got the powers of the flash I was
thinking about doing that today but
there are so many big season 4 concepts
that I wanted to talk about rebirth
first so I will do Lazarus contract
sometime later this week but leave all
your requests for flash bonus videos
they'll start shooting the season in a
couple weeks so we'll have an idea of
what's going on behind the scenes so
once that happens I'll start doing
videos about that - congratulations to
Te'o you're the latest giveaway winner
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for more
flash season 4 and you can click here
for brand new Rick and Morty thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you